er hat joachim von fallois hallo in
berlin wie sie es aus bei ihnen kamen
bei ihnen schon jetzt vorschläge die uns
mal ein bisschen mehr vielleicht
aufrütteln und vielleicht mehr wach
machen
ja ich begrüße sie hier von der
fraktionsebene am montag ungewöhnlich
nicht wirklich den haushalts wochen
tagen die fraktionen
montagmorgen geht es ja dann schon los
mit dem bundesfinanzminister bei uns
live zu erleben ab 9 uhr 45 jahre und
heute also sitzung der
bundestagsfraktion das hauptthema
natürlich neben der
flüchtlingsproblematik die ja auch eine
ganz ganz große rolle spielt natürlich
das geld und die bewältigung nicht nur
dieses rekord haushaltes den christian
lindner dazu verantworten hat mit dem
100 milliarden vermögen haben sie ja
gerade im studio schon darüber
gesprochen für die bundeswehr auch
nochmal schulden von 100 milliarden
99,5 milliarden nimmt der
bundesfinanzminister die ist ja noch mal
auf und es wird einen weiteren
haushaltstitel geben der im moment noch
nicht fest zu schreiben ist denn das
wäre die folgekosten der
flüchtlingskrise und des krieges seien
und da ist es mit der harmonie auch
unter den ampel fraktionen gar nicht so
weit her nämlich die frage wie kann der
bürger entlastet werden bei der energie
wir haben sie ja mitbekommen die
diskussion christian lindner hatte
vorgeschlagen an der tankstelle 20 oder
40 cent pro liter
das fanden die anderen beiden fraktionen
nicht so lustig weil das sozial nicht
abgefedert sei so die argumentation von
spd und grünen die grünen werben ja
schon seit längerer zeit für einen
energie geld 75 euro da musste robert
habeck der bundeswirtschaftsminister am
gestrigen tage allerdings dann zugeben
dass dieses geld unter die menschen zu
bringen gar nicht so einfach ist es gibt
dafür kein system es müsste ein neues
gesetz geschaffen werden ein
verteilsystem das dauert viel zu lange
so zunächst die kritik der beiden
anderen fraktionen
ja und dann hat der arbeitsminister
hubertus heil vorgeschlagen ein
mobilitäts geld zu bezahlen das da gibt
es um modelle ob die der wahrheit
entsprechen bleibt dann abzuwarten also
zum beispiel 40 euro für menschen die
ein einkommen haben bis 2000 euro soll
der arbeitgeber dann auszahlen und 20
euro für menschen ab 4000 euro und mal
sehen was die opposition dazu zu sagen
hatte dietmar bartsch der fraktionschef
der linksfraktion wird jetzt hier heute
als erster den aufschlag machen
auch von mir entschieden tag meine damen
und herren ausnahmsweise heute an einem
montag wie sie wissen haushaltswoche
bevor ich aber zum haushalt kommen
möchte ich natürlich ein paar wenige
bemerkung zu dem uns alle am meisten
bewegenden thema ukraine krieg machen
jeden tag erreichen uns aus der ukraine
schreckensbilder und auch
schreckensmeldungen ein brutaler krieg
dutzende unschuldige ukrainische kinder
wurden ermordet tausende zivilisten sind
gestorben millionen menschen haben
inzwischen ihre heimat verlassen es gibt
zerstörte wohnhäuser
raketen bomben fallen
auf die steht in der ukraine
die linke bleibt dabei dass wir alles
unterstützen wo es
diplomatische
lösung geben kann wir unterstützen die
bundesregierung alle anderen
gesprächsformat putins verbrechen müssen
so schnell es geht beendet werden dass
der die kapitulation einfordert und
weiter boomt das ist ein verbrechen
gegen das völkerrecht und
putin ist zweifelsfrei ein
kriegsverbrecher ich will noch mal
betonen dass auch die
vermittlungsversuche in der türkei aus
der türkei von scholz von makro dass die
linke dieses ausdrücklich unterstützt
wir haben in der letzten woche ein
falsches verhalten der ampel nach dem
auftritt von herrn selensky gesehen ist
auch richtig dass sich jetzt führende
vertreter korrigiert haben und das
selbstständig kritisiert haben sowas
darf nicht wieder passieren und auch die
geschäftsordnungsdebatte wo es dann
keine reaktion gab das etwa doch zur
sache debattiert wird war für das haus
nicht angemessen
damit herren wir haben aber auch gesehen
dass es jetzt
seitens des wirtschaftsministers
reisen gibt die die energiesituation in
deutschland
verändern sollen ich sage dazu noch was
aber ehrlich gesagt sind das auch sehr
sehr
problematische richtungen 1 muss doch
klar sein wenn man im moment russland
nicht bewegen kann wenn ausgeschlossen
wird dass man die gaslieferungen etwa
einstellen lässt dann kann man trotzdem
nicht bei null bleiben denn bisher ist
es so dass die verträge eingehalten
werden sowohl was die liefermengen
betrifft als auch was die bezahlung
betrifft aber auch eine reduzierung
sagen wir um 10 prozent hätte eine
wirkung und ich finde dass die
bundesregierung auch darüber nachdenken
sollte
zweitens ich habe das gesagt
haushaltswoche
ich finde ausgesprochen problematisch
dass wir in dieser woche den haushalt
debattieren aber seitens der ampel schon
klar und deutlich gesagt worden ist es
wird ein ergänzungs haushalt geben diese
ergänzungs haushalt wird dann im mai
wenn die entscheidung getroffen werden
vorgelegt ich finde das höchst
problematisch dass wir in dieser woche
nicht wissen was die ampel real vorhat
ich sage ganz klar dieser haushalt ist
ein auf rüstungs haushalt mit einem
sozialpolitischen
streichorchester diese haushalt ist im
übrigen
koalitionsvertrags widrig man sich
anschaut was dort alles im
koalitionsvertrag steht und dann sieht
was die realität ist da ist das ein
vehementer widerspruch bei den
verteidigungsausgaben haben wir eine
steigerung auf 50 milliarden losgelöst
von den 100 milliarden die er noch in
einem sondervermögen zur verfügung
gestellt werden soll im
koalitionsvertrag ist davon die rede
dass jede jeder euro der in verteidigung
geht sich auch widerspiegeln sollte bei
entwicklungszusammenarbeit oder
humanitärer hilfe das sehen wir
ausdrücklich nicht da hätte ich mir auch
ein sondervermögen vorstellen können
viele vorhaben sind im haushalt
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt
kindergrundsicherung
zentrales projekt im koalitionsvertrag
von der linken auch von mir persönlich
ausdrücklich unterstützt kein cent
verschiebebahnhof bürgergeld statt hartz
4 erst mal offensichtlich gestrichen
zusätzliches elterngeld erstmal
offensichtlich gestrichen wird auch
daran erinnern dass vor tische alle drei
parteien gesagt haben dass es
eine große steuerreform geben sollte spd
grüne und fdp waren der auffassung dass
bei kleinen und mittleren einkommen
entlastet werden muss auch davon sieht
man in diesem haushalt nichts was
allerdings gut läuft ist die verwaltung
der riesigen vermögen christian lindner
ist der minister für
vermögensverwaltung des geldadels in
deutschland meine damen und herren es
ist so dass niemand auf die idee kommt
in dieser situation vielleicht mal
ernsthaft über eine vermögensabgabe
einmalig oder eine vermögenssteuer
wieder erhebung nachzudenken sagt sehr
viel über die ampel man ist bereit
schulden größenordnung aufzunehmen mir
ist völlig unklar wie dann selbst das
ziel was immer postuliert wird dass man
gegebenenfalls die schuldenbremse
nächsten einheiten will wie das erreicht
werden soll das ist wenn überhaupt nur
wird taschenspielertricks möglich ich
glaube keine sekunde daran dass das
passieren wird letztlich muss man klar
und deutlich sagen die höheren ausgaben
für verteidigung werden am ende des
tages von den kleinen leuten getragen
das werden wir als linke nicht
akzeptieren es ist völlig klar dass wir
wenn sie denn an steht eine
entsprechende grundgesetzänderung für
das sondervermögen nicht zustimmen
werden ein dritter punkt den ich
erwähnen will oder zu dem ich etwas
sagen will der im moment die menschen
umtreibt und extrem bewegt das ist das
thema energiepreise dass es generell die
preisentwicklung auch angesichts der
inflationsentwicklung in deutschland die
preise für heizen für strom für
grundnahrungsmittel sind extrem hoch und
es wird in der koalition über vieles
geredet aber eins würde ich mal
festhalten etwas wirklich schlimmes
bisher hat es keinen einzigen euro reale
entlastung gegeben zehn länder in
unserer nachbarschaft haben sehr
unterschiedliche instrumente angewandt
um die bürgerinnen und bürger zu
entlasten in deutschland wird darüber
geredet die ampel diskutiert und
diskutiert widerspricht sich aber es
wird nichts entschieden da werden auch
bei mir wirklich erinnerungen an die
groko wach das sehr viel geredet wird
aber in der praxis wenig gemacht wird
christian linder hat von einem tank
rabatt gesprochen
meiner sicht sehr bürokratisch spd und
grüne reden jetzt vom ein mobilitäts
geld was denn nun wie bei ampeln was
denn was passiert real zur entlastung
der bürgerinnen und bürger wir sehen im
übrigen beides kritisch der tank rabatt
sichert vor allem die
spekulationsgewinne der
mineralölkonzerne warum wird übrigens da
nicht mal nachgedacht angesichts der
wahnsinnigen gewinne die gemacht werden
etwas abzuholen und das mobilitäts geld
auch da ist vieles unklar was ist dann
mit familien was ist mit kindern erhält
die alleinerziehende arbeitnehmerinnen
denselben betrag wie das kinderlose
single diese fragen alle sind nicht
beantwortet das mobilitäts geld soll
dazu wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe
befristet sein 50 euro drei monate das
sind maximal
150 euro und wenn ich dann robert habeck
ernst nehme der gesagt hat 2000 euro
werden die mehrkosten für gas für eine
familie sein dann ist das meines
erachtens völlig unangemessen ich weiß
auch nicht beantwortet ist ja mit
selbstständigen was ist mit rentnerinnen
und rentnern das ist mit den kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen mit der bäckerei
das alles ist nicht beantwortet und ich
erwarte dass jetzt zügig entscheidung
vorgelegt werden und ich will noch mal
wiederholen ich hab das mehrfach
öffentlich getan die mehreinnahmen auf
die gesteigerten preise nur durch die
mehrwertsteuer sind im haushalt 20
milliarden euro und ich erwarte von der
koalition dass wenigstens dieses geld an
die bürgerinnen und bürger zurückgegeben
wird ansonsten bleiben die minister für
wirtschaft und der für finanzen
ankündigungsminister ich hoffe auf
schnelles handeln gerade auch in die
halt haushaltswoche olaf scholz hat die
gelegenheit am mittwoch vor der
elefantenrunde oder in der
elefantenrunde klar zu sagen was dann
den die nächsten wochen passieren wird
dankeschön vielen dank dietmar bartsch
gibt es nachfragen dazu
als zum ersten punkt habe ich eben etwas
gesagt ich will das gern wiederholen ich
finde dass man jetzt neue
autokraten regime als partner finden
will weil es opportun es widerspricht
all dem was die grünen frösche gesagt
wurden haben uns wurde vorgeworfen wir
haben ein
unterschiedliches verhältnisse
autokraten offensichtlich ist dass bei
den grünen
auf jeden fall so und wenn ich mir
anschaue dass noch vor der
bundestagswahl
die heutige bundesaußenminister in immer
gefordert hat man müsse die fußball wm
in katar stoppen weil es dort
menschenrechtsverletzungen gibt weil die
arbeitsbedingungen so unmöglich sind
dann wundere ich mich dass das heute so
ein edler partner sein soll ich sehe das
sehr sehr kritisch von einem autokraten
zum nächsten autokraten zu gehen ich
würde mir wünschen dass das was auch
immer postuliert wird der schnellere
ausbau erneuerbarer energien
mit anderen ländern die zusammenarbeit
suchen und dann darüber nachzudenken wie
man vielleicht stück für stück die
lieferung aus russland reduzieren kann
das wäre meines erachtens der bessere
weg natürlich muss man an der situation
auch gegebenenfalls mit derartigen
leuten sprechen aber dann soll man auch
ehrlich sein und nicht die moralische
keule anderen gegenüber schwingen was
die atomkraft betrifft ist die position
der linken sehr klar und eindeutig wir
haben damals die entscheidung in
deutschland aus der atomkraft
auszusteigen begrüßt glaube auch nicht
dass die atomkraft das mittel wäre die
energiefragen in deutschland zu weil die
damit verbundenen gefahren und das thema
der endlagerung sind in keiner weise
auch für die bisherigen atomkraftwerke
geklärt und deswegen ist das bundes
erachtens der falsche ansatz gibt es
weitere fragen frau kaiser
parteien verbote in der ukraine in
dieser situation finde ich auch falsch
ich glaube dass die tätigkeit
politischer parteien derzeit mindestens
eingeschränkt ist deswegen glaube ich
auch nicht dass parteien verbote hier
wirklich helfen und dass sie in
irgendeiner weise zur beendigung des
krieges beitragen würden deswegen sehe
ich das also auch nicht als einen weg an
ich habe noch einmal dafür alles
mögliche zu unternehmen dass die waffen
schnell schweigen ob da diese
parteiverbote dazu gehören da habe ich
meine zweifel
in diesem sinne theilig dort die sicht
gibt es weitere fragen bitte schön
da werde ich auch mal am tag wird das
war für heldt fordert hat
seit tagen das sollte er auch bekommen
in sachen machen
also es sind zwei sehr verschiedene
dinge das eine ist aus meiner sicht die
unangemessene reaktion
katrin göring-eckardt hat dafür
selbstkritik geübt an sich das finde ich
richtig das finde ich angemessen und das
war völlig falsch auf der anderen seite
ist natürlich nicht nur meine position
sondern offensichtlich auch die der
bundesregierung dass man die forderung
von herrn see lenski so nicht umsetzen
kann ein verbot eine flugverbotszone
wäre verheerend würde die gefahr eines
dritten weltkrieges ausdrücklich
verschärfen mal ganz davon ab ob sie
überhaupt durchsetzbar ist und ähnlich
sehe ich das mit anderen punkten aber
das ist nicht der punkt das herz elends
die forderung hat die auch wir als linke
nicht teilen das ist keine überraschung
aber trotzdem ist es angemessen wenn er
eine rede im deutschen bundestag hält
per video das man dann nicht zur
tagesordnung übergeht das ist falsch die
geschäftsordnungsdebatte
danach wohl eher union und linke eine
position hatten wir selten genug
vorkommt die war richtig und spätestens
da hätte man einlenken müssen um punkt
setzen müssen eine pause machen und dann
zu den positionen sich verständigen denn
niemand hätte etwas neues sagen müssen
aber nach diesen eindringlichen wunsch
muss man auch schon sagen warum man die
eine oder andere forderung als
bundesregierung nicht teilt und dann
hätte sicherlich auch die linke
vielleicht sogar ich selbst sich dazu
geäußert
vielen dank ich sehe keine weiteren
fragen
damit beende ich das presse statement
und danke ihnen für ihr erscheint danke
danke schön
jaja so weit also dietmar bartsch der
fraktionschef der linksfraktion er hat
ja noch mal die kritik deutlich gemacht
in den verschiedenen punkten anders wird
das sicherlich christian dürr sie in der
fraktionschef der fdp logisch er ist ja
auch einer von denen die dieses land
mitregieren in der ampel christian doerr
natürlich die gesamten westen ich habe
mich in der vergangenen woche dazu auch
mit dem ukrainischen botschafter manic
ausgetauscht und er hat mir noch mal die
situation seiner landsleute in der
ukraine geschildert für deutschland ist
klar wir stehen weiter an der seite der
ukraine und wir sehen jetzt in
deutschland natürlich auch die
auswirkungen dieser kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung immer mehr menschen
machen sich auf den weg um sich selbst
in sicherheit und ihre familien in
sicherheit zu bringen
und deswegen ist die
flüchtlingssituation eine mit der wir
uns jetzt auch in deutschland noch
eindringlicher beschäftigen müssen die
zahlen des uhren hcr sprechen da eine
eindeutige sprache der un hcr geht von
10 millionen menschen aus die aus der
ukraine bereits geflohen sind und
insofern sollten wir unsere solidarität
hier weiter aufrechterhalten in
deutschland die deutsche bevölkerung ist
sehr bereit dazu und das freut mich
ausdrücklich diese aufnahmebereitschaft
erfordert eben aber auch koordination
und sofern schlagen wir als freie
demokraten vor dass es ein
internationales friedenstreffen ein
internationales krisentreffen
entschuldigung ein internationales
krisentreffen geben wird auf einen
solchen internationalen gipfel muss über
die verteilung der geflüchteten menschen
gesprochen werden es muss das ziel sein
der westlichen länder dass wir hier an
einem strang ziehen insbesondere um die
humanitäre unterbringung der menschen
aus der ukraine in westlichen ländern zu
gewährleisten die frage der koordination
darf hier natürlich den besten nicht
spalten denn genau das ist das ziel von
wladimir putin deswegen wäre es gut wenn
die innenministerin ein solches
internationales krisentreffen
initiiert damit wir hier einen schritt
weiterkommen ich habe vernommen dass die
bundesministerin dem vorschlag des
nordrhein westfälischen
integrationsministers joachim stamp
einer luftbrücke folgt und sagt dass das
eine gute idee so menschen aus der
ukraine in sicherheit zu bringen das war
der erste punkt der zweite den ich
ansprechen möchte ist die beratung die
zurzeit laufen über entlastung für die
menschen die ja auch betroffen sind von
den auswirkungen aufgrund der hohen und
stark gestiegene energiepreise in den
letzten tagen und wochen wir müssen uns
an dieser stelle natürlich auch in
deutschland mit den folgen dieser
auseinandersetzung des russischen
angriffs auseinandersetzen als erstes
hat ja die ampel koalition schon vor
einigen wochen ein entlastungspaket
politisch vereinbart wir bringen das
jetzt auf den weg sie wissen dass die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage ein
heizkostenzuschuss den wir jetzt noch
einmal als ampelkoalition verdoppelt
haben und derzeit laufen beratungen über
ein zweites entlastungspaket es ist
bekannt dass die fdp vorgeschlagen hat
christian lindner als
bundesfinanzminister hier in deutschland
einen tank rabatt einzuführen damit die
autofahrenden autofahrer die
beispielsweise für den arbeitsweg auf
das auto angewiesen sind direkt an der
ladenkasse der tankstelle entlastet
werden als ampelkoalition sind wir uns
einig dass es hier entlastung braucht
wir werden in dieser woche weiter
darüber reden denn zur wahrheit gehört
eben auch dass wir als ampelkoalition
hier ein doppeltes erbe antreten
einerseits die doch erhebliche und in
den letzten jahren leider gestiegenen
abhängigkeit von russischen rohstoffen
und auf der anderen seite bereits in der
vergangenheit sehr hohe energiepreise
mit hohem steuerlasten die die menschen
bereits in der vergangenheit belastet
haben aber jetzt vor dem hintergrund der
gestiegenen rohstoffpreise eben noch
viel mehr in dieser woche wie gesagt
gehen die beratungen weiter und in dem
zusammenhang ist mir noch mal wichtig zu
betonen in welchem kontext das ganze ist
das schärfste schwert was wir gegen
putin haben ist unsere wirtschaftliche
stärke das ist die wirtschaftliche
stärke des westens und auch die
wirtschaftliche stärke der
bundesrepublik deutschland der dritte
punkt den ich ansprechen will ist das
thema haushalt wir werden ja eine
haushalts sitzungswoche im deutschen
bundestag haben der zweite
regierungsentwurf für den haushalt
2022 ist durch bundesfinanzminister
durch das kabinett gebracht worden es
gibt eine finanzplanung bis zum jahr
2026 und das ziel der ampelkoalition an
dieser stelle ist klar wir wollen unsere
stabilität sichern wir wollen
handlungsfähig bleiben wir wollen
nachhaltiger werden und
zukunftsinvestitionen stärken und vor
allen dingen wollen wir unser
wirtschaftswachstum weiter fördern denn
ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt gerade
die wirtschaftliche stärke ist in diesen
schwierigen tagen wichtiger denn je
indem wir klare prioritäten setzen
schaffen wir es die geplante
nettokreditaufnahme die bereits von der
großen koalition so geplant war
entsprechend zu halten 99,7 milliarden
euro beträgt die netto kreditaufnahme
für das haushaltsjahr
2022 das ist der rahmen den die große
koalition bereits gesteckt hatte und das
war noch vor einer zusätzlichen
mehrbelastung die ja auch auf den
bundeshaushalt zugekommen ist aufgrund
der weiter anhaltenden corona pandemie
und ganz wichtig natürlich für die
freien demokraten das ist möglich diesen
rahmen zu halten auch ohne
steuererhöhungen ganz im gegenteil wir
reden ja in diesen tagen über entlastung
für die menschen aber natürlich steht
dieser bundeshaushalt auch im zeichen
der krise und des krieges in der ukraine
es wird deshalb einen ergänzungs
haushalt insbesondere für die humanitäre
hilfe geben damit die leistung für
geflüchtete auch durch den
bundeshaushalt abgesichert sind und dann
werden wir auch weitere entlastung für
die menschen in deutschland in diesem
rahmen über einen ergänzungs haushalt
auf den weg bringen können wichtig ist
hier wir wollen eine klare trennung
zwischen kriegsbeginn ausgaben auf der
einen seite und dem kernhaushalt des
bundes mit den zukunftsaufgaben die ich
eben skizziert habe auf der anderen
seite das gilt genauso für das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr sie
wissen dass der bundeskanzler in seiner
regierungserklärung angekündigt hat 100
milliarden euro zusätzlich für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung zu stellen das
ist etwas was leider von den
unionsgeführten bundesregierungen in der
vergangenheit sträflich vernachlässigt
worden ist hier werden wir jetzt nach
finanzieren und dieses projekt hat
natürlich nach wie vor die volle
unterstützung auch der fraktion der
freien demokraten
ich habe schon gesagt wirtschaftliche
stärke ist ein wichtiger punkt für uns
und ein instrument um deutschland stark
zu halten ist auch die schuldenbremse
denn wir haben es mit der schuldenbremse
in die letzten zehn jahren geschafft den
bundeshaushalt in deutschland zu
konsolidieren aus dieser stärke heraus
können wir jetzt agieren und insofern
ist ein herr ein festhalten an der
schuldenbremse sehr wichtig denn das
führt auch in zukunft dazu dass wir
entsprechend als bunt reagieren können
die aktuelle lage bestätigt mich und
bestätigt die fraktion der freien
demokraten deswegen ist es unser großes
interesse dass die schuldenbremse
erhalten bleibt dass wir sie weiter
stärken und nicht schwächen das wäre das
falscheste was wir dieser tage tun
können ich freue mich gerade als
ehemaliger haushaltspolitiker der
fraktion der fdp natürlich auf die
haushaltsberatungen dann auch auf die
debatte am kommenden mittwoch über den
kanzleretat vielen dank
falls ihr gesprochen die entlastungen
diese gespräche mit den anderen parteien
sowie wichtig ist derzeit
nicht drin sein oder die noch einen
rummel entlasten
also es geht insbesondere um die
entlastung für diejenigen die auf das
auto angewiesen sind weil sie
beispielsweise zur arbeit pendeln
müssten den ist ja nicht geholfen wenn
man an anderer stelle sie entlastet
sondern sind aufs auto angewiesen
brauchen das sozusagen um ihr einkommen
zu sichern diese menschen müssen
entlastet werden darüber reden wir jetzt
in der ampelkoalition und ich bin auch
gespannt was es am ende als ergebnis
gibt aber das ziel muss eben sein dass
diejenigen die arbeiten die morgens
aufstehen hart arbeiten und zur arbeit
kommen müssen gerade auch im ländlichen
raum sie wissen ich komme aus
niedersachsen da ist mir besonders daran
gelegen dass diese menschen jetzt
entlastung erfahren und darüber werden
wir reden
wo man eben noch gezielt diejenigen
entlasten
der tasche haben bei den karabag
passiert ja jeder auch der e6 und x7
den vorschlägen auch der partner ist gar
nichts falsch sondern ganz im gegenteil
wir reden jetzt darüber und verschiedene
vorschläge auf dem tisch ich habe vorhin
gesagt es geht darum diejenigen zu
entlasten die gerade eine weitere
strecke jetzt zurücklegen müssen aufs
auto angewiesen sind und bei ein
pauschalbetrag ist das so nicht möglich
also der der eine längere strecke fährt
der hat zur zeit wesentlich schwerer
gerade für die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen ist es eine erhebliche
belastung die würden über den tank
rabatt entlastet deswegen dieser
vorschlag von christian hinter den ich
unterstütze und dann schauen wir mal was
am ende herauskommt aber ist schon
wichtig dass die autofahrenden
autofahrer die fahren müssen auch
entlastet werden und klar ist auch dass
an der tankstelle keine sozial prüfung
stattfinden kann deswegen würde es
sicherlich nicht das einzige instrument
sein
der bundeswirtschaftsminister
aber machen wir uns da nicht von anderen
despoten hat gerade die menschen
katar gehört
er ist etwa der
also zunächst mal unterstütze ich das
anliegen von robert habeck das ist unser
aller anliegen dass wir uns
diversifizieren dass wir breiter werden
mit dem was wir an rohstoffen
importieren und zur wahrheit gehört auch
dass deutschland auf importe von
rohstoffen von energierohstoffen auch in
zukunft angewiesen sein wird sie wissen
dass wir eine ampelkoalition auf den
ausbau der erneuerbaren in deutschland
stärker voran gehen bringen wollen als
die vorgängerregierung aber soweit
gehört eben auch dass das nicht
ausreichend wird sondern wir werden
energieimporte brauchen also brauchen
wir mehrere schwellenländer sozusagen
lassen sie mich gerade zum nahen osten
eines sagen das sind ja in aller regel
sehr sonnen intensive regionen und
deswegen haben wir als freie demokraten
im koalitionsvertrag ja auch das thema
synthetische kraftstoffe festgeschrieben
denn zur wahrheit gehört werden in
deutschland etwa 45 millionen pkws davon
sind mindestens 44 millionen
verbrennungsmotoren kann man in der
sache sicherlich drüber streiten aber
das wird sich kurzfristig nicht
abstellen dass und mein ziel ist es
gerade diese autos auch in zukunft die
chance haben co2 neutral zu fahren und
welche regionen sind besser geeignet um
co2 neutrale kraftstoffe also
synthetische kraftstoffe herzustellen
als die sonnenreichen regionen der erde
also da kann es auch neue
handelsbeziehungen geben mit dem
mittleren osten aber auch andere
regionen in dieser welt die viel sonne
haben denn dafür braucht es viel solare
energie insbesondere die herzustellen
aber ist eine echte chance um
diversifizierter zu sein auf der einen
seite und den schritt in richtung mehr
klimaneutralität zu schaffen insofern
ist das eine chance wenn da neue quellen
kommen auch co2 neutrale quellen kommen
die wir nach deutschland importieren
können ist das ein großer fortschritt
große nachfrage jetzt eigentlich
verboten abhängig gemacht erkennen dass
jetzt
ist immer eine frage der option dass es
keine frage aber zurzeit gibt es
jedenfalls von dort auch aus katar eine
kriegerische auseinandersetzung auf die
weltgemeinschaft keine verletzung des
völkerrechts ich anerkenne das was sie
sagen auch zu den zu der schwierigen
menschenrechtsfrage auch das teile ich
aber natürlich ist es wichtig in so
einer situation nicht die hände in den
schoß zu legen und quasi zu hause zu
bleiben insofern begrüße ich das was der
bundeswirtschaftsminister dort macht
diversifizieren und schauen was jetzt
kurzfristig geht denn wir werden ja und
dass das ziel kurzfristig bereits die
erdgasimporte aus russland ersetzen
wollen es ein grund warum wir auch
anstrengen flüssiggasterminals zu
errichten in brunsbüttel in
wilhelmshaven aber ich sage auch als
niedersachse stade wird ausdrücklich
auch dazu ein projekt war schon sehr
weit gediehen ist also diese
diversifizierung ist ein erster
wichtiger schritt und im zweiten das was
ich vorhin gesagt habe auch zu der
möglichkeit klimaneutrale stoffe
insbesondere in form von synthetischen
kraftstoffen zu importieren also
insofern macht es sinn dort zu sprechen
er gibt es ja nicht sofort regierung
braucht manchmal gestern verstehen dass
eine ansammlung von hedgefonds so weit
gehen kann das herz des bundes sagte
transport ist und man könnte es
weiterhin ganze theorie kann sich das
wort wäre das im sinne finden
naja wenn alle landkreise und alle
kreisfreien städte in deutschland
hotspot sind dann geht das was ich schon
vor einigen wochen gesagt habe als ich
gesagt habe mit dem 19 märz müssen wir
zur normalität in deutschland
zurückkehren da müssen wir uns natürlich
haben die nationale lager muss ist als
deutscher bundestag wieder damit
beschäftigen aber klar ist auch es kann
mehrere landkreise in einem bundesland
geben es seine option
wir wollten den bundesländern die
möglichkeit geben jetzt findet das
telefon wir wollten den bundesländern in
deutschland die möglichkeit geben auf
besondere situationen zu reagieren und
das geben wir den bundesländern damit
diese möglichkeit und herr lauterbach
hat ja noch was weiteres gesagt ich
würde die wortwahl jetzt gar nicht mehr
zu eigen mache aber ich fand es
interessant hat gesagt es wäre blöd wenn
jetzt einige ministerpräsidenten quasi
die beleidigte leberwurst spielen denn
ja sie müssen jetzt die landtage fragen
aber als jemand der auch einen großen
wert auf die legislative als
gesetzgebendes organ legt sagt das ist
auch richtig dass die landtage davor
stehen das ist auch finde ich keine
erschweren ist sondern der deutsche
bundestag hat gezeigt dass er schnell
handlungsfähig ist ich bin mir ganz
sicher den hotspots entstehen sind es
auch die bundesländer die sehr schnell
handlungsfähig sind und insofern bin ich
da in diesen tagen sehr ball- karl
lauterbach bin ich grundsätzlich bei
diesen tagen besonderen einerseits was
die hotspot regelung betrifft aber
insgesamt was die rückkehr zur
normalität betrifft denn er hat ja auch
gesagt wir dürfen uns jetzt von leider
wenigen auch die über 60 sind die noch
nicht geimpft sind ich darf an der
stelle aufrufen dass all diejenigen die
es noch nicht sind gerade ältere
menschen dass sie sich jetzt endgültig
auch impfen lassen das ist ganz ganz
wichtig aber wir dürfen davon unsere
freiheit nicht einschränken lassen
insofern ist das der richtige schritt
und ich habe den eindruck dass sich
langsam bei dem einen oder anderen
insbesondere unionsminister präsenten
auch die gemütslage wieder etwas
beruhigt parlamente gehören einer
demokratie dazu und will man reagieren
muss dann haben eine möglichkeit
geschaffen insofern ist das ein gutes
paket
vielen dank diesmal stelle ich auch
meine telefon aus entschuldigung
ja soweit also christian doerr der fdp
fraktionschef kein wunder dass er mit
dem infektionsschutzgesetz was ja
vergangene woche verabschiedet wurde
sehr zufrieden ist da hat sich die fdp
doch ziemlich massiv durchgesetzt er hat
noch mal zum impfen aufgerufen wir haben
jetzt in den letzten tagen immer mehr
erfahren können dass unter den
todesopfern mittlerweile auch wieder
viele gepostete sind weil dieser booster
eben nicht lang genug ausreicht darüber
muss die politik hier in berlin jetzt
auch informieren dass ältere jetzt zur
vierten impfung gehen müssen um sich
selber zu schützen gewusst hätte stecken
ja andere mitmenschen leider auch an das
ist auch nicht die lösung insofern nur
schwer zu verstehen warum es gerade die
liberalen waren die darauf gesetzt haben
die masten zb beim einkauf abzuschaffen
im umkehrschluss bedeutet das dass viele
gruppen die bei weitem nicht nur in
altersheimen wohnen sondern mitten unter
uns das sind zum beispiel krebspatienten
asthma patienten und andere die werden
schwierigkeiten haben gefahrlos zum
beispiel ihre lebensmittel einzukaufen
aber das ist die diskussion der
vergangenen woche die diskussionen die
dieser woche ist nicht nur das
haushaltsgesetz sondern vor allen dingen
auch die frage wie werden denn jetzt die
bürger schnell entlastet und ich tippe
mal da wird sich die fdp mit ihren tank
vorschlägen ihres vorsitzenden nicht
durchsetzen das hat sich in den letzten
tagen schon gezeigt dass die grünen und
vor allen dingen die spd da ganz anderer
meinung sind heute abend tagt dazu eine
arbeitsgruppe und man möchte möglichst
schnell entscheiden wie man die bürger
bei den gestiegenen preisen
energiepreisen vor allen dingen
entlasten kann und das muss dann auch
wirklich schnell gehen und vor allen
dingen praktikabel sein bleibt
abzuwarten was die anderen
fraktionschefs hier heute noch dazu zu
sagen haben zum beispiel rolf mützenich
von der spd den erwarten wir gleich kurz
vor 4 und dann melden wir uns hier aus
berlin wieder und damit zurück zu thomas
bade nach bonn
vielen dank gehört joachim von fallois
glaube 15 45 hatten wir gedacht dass wir
es nicht das wieder nach berlin schalten
zu den fraktionen geht ja auch im falle
hat ja gerade gesagt erwartet dann rolf
mützenich wir haben mit der zwischenzeit
hier einen zweiten tagesordnungspunkt
auf den wir warten wir versuchen nämlich
die außenministerin live abzupassen in
berlin dessen in brüssel verfügung die
ist heute in brüssel beim eu
außenministerin treffen und wird in
diesen minuten sich von dort live
einem kurzen gespräch zur verfügung
stellen und wie immer bei phoenix
versuchen wir das natürlich elegant
abzupassen und zu diesem zwecke freue
ich mich sehr dass professor volker
kronenberg weiter hier im studio ist und
wir haben die gelegenheit ganz kurz
darüber zu sprechen was wir eben in der
vergangenen viertelstunde gehört haben
es ging zum teil um energie es ging zum
teil darum dass der bundesaußenminister